ozethic success stories are all over
social media but these highlight reels
don't give us all the facts so I'm gonna
give you a sneak peek behind the
Highlight Reel through my friend's
weight loss Journey with expert
commentary in real time honestly I
didn't even expect some of this hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
a quick disclaimer that this video may
include numbers calories and Extreme
Weight Loss discussion so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also note
that the individual in this series is
not my client so any suggestions that I
make are for general knowledge only not
directed specifically at her everyone's
needs are unique and ultimately should
be discussed one-on-one with your
healthcare provider okay so assuming
you've opened a social media app or like
left your house in the past year you've
probably heard about ozempic there are
ads for at the medi spa at the movies on
Tick Tock everywhere and for once it's
maybe not just hype I've been following
the research and I gave my somewhat
shocking take in my videos here and here
and despite what you may expect to hear
from an anti-diet diet dietitian
honestly I think it's going to be a
powerful tool for better or worse I do
worry that it will be use and abuse and
serve to reinforce some pretty damaged
big body standards but I also think it's
going to save and change a lot of lives
and at the end of the day I believe in
body autonomy so when my close friend
talent agent and my business partner
told me that she was starting the drug I
didn't try to talk her out of it I
didn't shame her for succumbing to diet
culture I simply asked her if there was
anything I could do to help so
semic or starting your own glp-1 egg in
this journey this mini-series will give
you the unfiltered unscripted messy
truth yep we're gonna be going there
with The Good The Bad and The Diarrhea
lots of it
[Music]
hello Ginger I am so happy you're
joining uh Ginger and I have known each
other for so long how long oh gosh 12
maybe almost 15 years yeah I mean back
in my early blogging days Ginger hired
me to host an event for Jamie Oliver
um and that was so so fun and now we are
business partners in a very exciting
Adventure she has she signed me on a
while ago as part of her agency roster
so yeah we go way back way back back
which has been great I mean we're
friends we're colleagues we've done so
much together and now we're doing this
together so talk about vulnerability and
yes you know switching the table and
thank you for being so vulnerable this
is such an important story to share and
journey to share and I know that that's
not necessarily very easy so thank you
for for being here so
um why don't we start off why don't you
tell me a little bit about your you know
your weight and diet history where did
this all start for you yeah sure so I've
been overweight my whole life
um and I think it's funny because my my
parents are divorced and I'm not sure if
if you know the way they've treated me
with food has been so different I don't
know if that's why I'm so you know in
between and how I think about food I
don't know but
um you know growing up my mom
um you know her family didn't have a lot
of money so they were always taught to
eat everything and never leave anything
left on the plate and you know you never
know when you're gonna get your next
meal sort of thing so that she kind of
brought into my life like I would have
to fall asleep at the table if I didn't
eat the meal yeah it's like the physical
scarcity mentality carries on to mental
scarcity mentality
exactly and and I obviously when you're
a kid you don't recognize that that's
what they're doing and that's there it's
coming from them you know and then my
parents were divorced so they got
divorced when I was two so my dad's
family I mean when we got to see my dad
which was every other week that was the
that was the custody Arrangement back
then uh almost for every uh family
um and uh you know we were rewarded with
food so in one situation it was you're
not allowed to leave the table until
you've eaten all this nutritious food
even if it was Beefaroni like if that's
what we were eating that week I had to
eat it you know my mom got you know
payback a couple times and I vomited it
up but
um and then my dad said it was like I
got the donuts I got all the fun stuff
and and so a real complex mix of how I
approached food from that kind of very
young age yeah food just could never
just be food it had to be tied with all
this other emotional moral weight you
got it you got you got it and obviously
you don't know and they don't know like
it
was so young
yeah you know so I get it I get it but
here I am you know and both sides of the
family suffer from diabetes and heart
issues and whatnot so no matter what I
was gonna struggle with something you
know
um and so here I am I've struggled my
whole life you know my mom took me to
Weight Watchers when I was 10.
um and you think okay I'm going to this
thing I'm gonna meet people and I'm so
extroverted you know meeting people's
cool but I'm weighing myself by a 10 at
10. it was I don't think I knew then
what I know now and like I would never
ever do that to my kids of course and
you know generational diet culture it's
so hard to break that cycle and you know
of course your mom was probably just
doing what she was taught was best from
her mom and by Society at large and so
you know no we can't shame our parents
for making these choices when they
really were doing it in our best
interest us or what they believed was in
our best interest but now of course when
we know better we can do better and we
know that kids put on diets are more
likely to grow up to be overweight
adults and to suffer from low
self-esteem body dissatisfaction
disordered eating Etc so we do things
very differently now but yeah I mean it
sounds like you grew up with a lot of
mixed messages about food in your body
you got it and and and it was never
really like the focus was never food
that was kind of like
just what happened you know we weren't
talking about food I never really knew
how to eat or eat nutritiously or eat
you know we had the food guide back then
we never really looked at that it was
there was just polarizing ideas of you
know the mentality of we're gonna treat
ourselves with sugar and the mentality
of you have to eat everything on this
plate right
now that's that's what we've we're told
right and it's very common The Clean
Plate Club
um really teaches children to dissociate
themselves with their innate hunger and
fullness cues at a very very young age
when kids are born intuitive eaters and
yet we are teaching them very clearly
how to you know how to cut ties with
that
um so that all that all makes sense to
me and so you mentioned you know you've
you've struggled with your weight for
most your adult life since going to
Weight Watchers at 10.
um can you tell me about like other than
Weight Watchers I guess what have you
tried has anything worked what diets
have you been put on or you know put
yourself on yeah oh my gosh I've done
them all ah no so I I relatively I'm
very healthy so all my blood work is
always clean but I've just been like a
healthy fat girl you know like and I
move I I do a lot of physical activity
and I just
um can't lose the weight for a number of
reasons you know diagnosed with PCOS
um you know and gosh anybody who has to
go through that I mean I feel you so
hard it's it's a struggle and and I know
what it's like so
um but you know how I got here uh when
I started this journey kind of on my own
my mom was always very thin so it was
natural to her to to be thin and even
though her family wasn't she was so
growing up and my mom also has a binge
eating issue I I shouldn't say binge
eating but you know if it's there she's
gonna eat it similar to me you know if
it's there I'm gonna eat it so growing
up we we never really had the sweets or
or anything in the cupboard because she
would eat it so right when I would be
out of the house I would binge on all
the things that I couldn't get in the
house so I got your money or if I got
five bucks or ten bucks I was going to
the candy machine you know uh and so as
a result I became addicted to Sugar so I
definitely and I'm still addicted so
trying to cut that out is really hard
but you know I've run the gamut from I
think in high school you know I was I
was dancing so I was moving all the time
but I was never super thin and and then
finally I just became anorexic I just
stopped eating
um you know a Diet Coke was my lunch
um and some days after dinner because
I'd be eating with my family I would
throw it up but I I that was not a
regular thing so I wouldn't say I was I
went through a bulimic phase
um I don't think that's fair to say I
think that but I did go through a phase
um but no I just kind of stopped eating
and you know hearing everybody saying oh
my God you're looking so good you're
looking so good will you just keep doing
it right so
um but I'm that person who you know if I
have a goal in mind I'm gonna reach that
goal but as soon as I reach it I give up
so it's like I just and that's the
problem with yo-yo dieting right like
you reach it and then oh my God it's not
sustainable I'm done I can't do it
anymore and then you go back you go back
and often the weight is not only going
to go back to where it was but it you
may even gain even more so wow what a
story uh Ginger that was a lot to share
and I'm sure so many people who are
listening are thinking that is my story
to a t you know the mom who was skinny
and always restricting and of course if
you're being restricted in the household
you are going to binge you're putting
all these Foods on a pedestal so as a
child there's no way for you not to be
enticed to try to get the forbidden
fruit and so none of what you've told me
surprises me even though it's completely
heartbreaking and and just terrible
um so yeah thank you for sharing that
that that's that's a lot so all right
yeah you're here no I know and tell me
you're you're you're how old now
38 turning 39 next week okay so you're
at the point you're 39 you're almost 40.
why ozone pick why now what what how did
this kind of come to be as your next
step
actually it all started my interest in
news epic started with
um I was going through the egg freezing
so I split from my partner and then I
was like oh okay well I'm 37 what am I
doing here so I just went through the
process because I needed to uh and then
in that process my doctor talked to me
about metformin as
um as a tool to help with reproduction
um and so from that conversation we
started talking about ozempic and you
know I was curious about it I had seen
the ads great obviously everywhere yeah
um you know so and that's kind of how we
started talking about it but my doctor
was really good and and if I if I back
up just a little bit here my dad is on
those epic so my dad has Type 2 diabetes
so you know layering life he became a
diabetic he's had a stroke you know
multiple he's got six siblings
um you know several of them have had
heart attacks or triple bypasses
um several of them have diabetes so it
runs in the family so you know he was
also a healthy fat boy his whole life
and then got diabetes later in age
um and his doctor put him on ozempic and
he dropped weight like this I had no
idea he was on those epic until New
Year's this year when I was talking
about my doctor talked about metformin
dad what do you think he's like well I'm
monozepic and Metformin I was like
you're on ozembic what and then my
aunt's like I'm on a zombic too and I'm
like yeah it's like when the floodgates
open everyone kind of starts talking
yeah and so and they both lost so much
weight but I have no idea I never really
thought to ask I don't see them all the
time my dad doesn't live in the same
city and so that's when I started to
take it seriously I'm like okay I think
I have to look at this more seriously
um and my dad's doctor actually told him
that it was a miracle drug she's never
actually seen results with any drug the
way she's she's seen ozempic change
people's lives that's true so many
reasons yes you know not just diabetic
treatment not just blood sugar control
but for so many things and you know when
we talk about obesity as being an
epidemic well especially well in the
states North America and Canada
um
you know think about the health care
dollars we could save if we could treat
obesity earlier on
anyways that turned into a whole thing
totally talked to my doctor and my
doctor was really good my doctor was
like we're gonna do the blood work we're
gonna have a consult with internal
medicine because I was always going I
was also going through some gallbladder
issues and we're gonna have a consult
with the weight loss clinic so I did all
those things and the weight loss clinic
was the one who actually confirmed yes
this is what you should be on given your
history given your family history if you
go on now you will likely be in a
preventative situation where you will
not get diabetes and you will not have
heart issues right so to summarize you
have family history of heart disease and
diabetes and are overweight and so your
doctor suggesting this would be a really
good tool to prevent you from following
in your genetic you know genetically
determined potential path you got it
yeah exactly yep conclusion exclamation
mark That's exactly right and you've
told me in the past that one of the
challenges that you've always had is
just never feeling full you know we talk
on about on this channel all the time
about uh you know paying attention and
honing in on your hunger and fullness
cues but I acknowledge all the time that
that's just not possible for a lot of
people and it sounds like that may be
the case for you can you talk about that
yeah you got it I never feel full
um that that and that's that's one of
the things in my personal research in
the in what the doctors have told me is
that ozempic will help connect the dots
from brain to stomach
um I'm not there yet if I'm being
totally honest
um so I still am hungry
um but yes I never really feel full I
never feel satiated
um I I just don't have that that that
indicator that key that brain connection
that tells me you're full yeah even you
put anything else in here and you know I
can imagine given everything that you've
gone through in your kind of diet and
body history and then also compounded by
the fact that like physically and
physiologically you aren't getting those
cues that's that that is that makes it
virtually impossible for you to have a
normal relationship with food and your
body because you're not getting the
feedback from your body and so it is
very hard to trust your body and that's
very commonly why people get into these
cycles of overeating binge eating
anorexia other eating disorders and it's
very hard to get out and so and that's a
story like I feel like that when I hear
that people have those cues and like
tell me more right I've never
experienced it before so I don't really
understand and that doesn't necessarily
compute for me right this is going to be
a bit of a hot take but I think and you
know this nomax area expertise but I
believe that it is very likely that a
drug like ozempic or other glp-1
agonists will be used in the treatment
of eating disorders that are
particularly
around lack of hunger fullness cues you
know binge eating disorder overeating
things like that because even
potentially in the absence of obesity
because I know and I can imagine how
debilitating it feels to just not have
not be wired that way it's impossible
for you to eat intuitively or normally
without that cue and so I think that
that's going to be a huge
um next area of practice when it comes
to these glp1 agonists huge area of
opportunity because there's a lot of
people there's a lot of people just
based on the the people who the you know
the fans and the followers and the
comments I get who are in the same boat
they do not feel fullness they don't or
hunger and it's just
I will say Abby if there's there's one
thing there's one tool that actually
helps me with with satiation is that a
word no satiety yes thank you
um it's the hunger crushing combo love
it say I have to say you know if I eat
enough of the the mix the combo yeah
that the protein and the fiber I will
feel full and if I feel full I'm like oh
was this a hunger crushing comment I
don't even realize that I'm doing here
it works yeah it does it does it does
and I I have to say that is one of the
things that has totally changed my now
if we're being totally honest you can't
always get a hunger crushing combo in
every meal you're having no especially
if you're on the go and for sure working
towards things that to help that you
know you and I sidebar yeah you're
trying and because I know it's working
for me yep
um you know we know that but
um when you do get it in I really do
find it it's it helps now do I still
have that cue no but when I do feel full
you know it it's usually yeah and it's
usually because I've eaten a fully yup a
nice full say trading meal with all
those compounds yes it is such a
powerful tool I will never say it's
going to replace a powerful anti-obesity
agent like glp1 Agonist uh more like
ozone pick but it is a great place to
start and I'm glad that you're having
success with it all right Ginger I'm
gonna let you get into that first shot
how are you with needles
okay I was terrified of needles but now
that I've gone through two rounds of egg
freezing give myself three or four
needles a day I think I'm ready for this
one I did take a little peek and it's
pretty small yeah so I'm ready I think
it's gonna be totally fine yeah us
ivfers know some of the those needles
are Honkers we can do anything now they
want to take my blood I'm like take it
honey like I'll be here all day and just
fine uh I mean listen if somebody's
gonna take my blood I'm still not
looking at the needle going yeah I don't
want to see it it's okay it's awesome
all right well thoughts and prayers to
your toilet bowl lots of good luck and I
will check in with you in a couple weeks
bye thanks Abby bye okay
it's day one it was epic it's Tuesday
May 9th I've had a roller coaster of a
couple of weeks a couple of months just
between egg freezing and uh gallbladder
surgery and then my dog getting attacked
throwing my back out I've gained about
um 25 30 pounds since last August and
it's time to get it off uh and I I want
to move I want to do all the things so
I'm starting ozempic today yeah I'm
starting those epic today I'm going to
take all of my measurements I'm going to
have my starting weight so that Abby can
review everything uh and here we go okay
so this is the pen
oh yeah here's my scars from the
gallbladder surgery so we're gonna go
here
oh he's gonna sleep yourself up for this
very small needle can't feel a thing so
I know Ginger really well and she has
been through hell and back this year and
as someone who's gone through IVF I can
attest that all those hormones they get
pumped full of in the egg freezing
process can and do cause weight gain and
that's all that's all on top of her
running a super successful very busy
business life stressors affect our risk
of weight gain through affecting our
sleep or increasing cortisol or
increasing emotional eating or all of
the above so I hope that Ginger can
offer herself some compassion because
yeah this year has not been kind okay so
I'm doing a little check-in
um this is the evening of my second dose
so week two second dose I'm at .25
milligrams I actually have to say that
my appetite was small today and I didn't
have much I had
um half of a tuna poke Bowl I had a
cookie I had a Diet Coke
um lots of water uh and then before my
um tennis lesson this evening I had a
small bowl of rice probably about three
quarters of a cup and a little piece of
salmon and as I was playing tennis and
this might be Emi so you might have to
like bleep bleep bleep this out but as I
was playing tennis I had to leave early
I was having some issues I I had my
gallbladder removed about four weeks ago
and I don't think I've ever driven home
so quickly in my life to run up to the
bathroom and
I almost shot my pants
oh Ginger
that's
so hard but also somewhat to be expected
diary is one of the most common side
effects of glp-1 agonists like ozone
pick especially when you're just
starting out or you're upping a dose the
rice is a great binding food also things
like oatmeal cream of wheat toast
bananas that can all help to slow down
the bowels I probably try to avoid the
diet coke because the caffeine can get
things moving and I'd also keep food
pretty mild and low in fat maybe going
easy on any kind of like spicy mayo or
sauces on the Poke Bowl it does make for
a pretty boring diet but better than
your pants in my opinion also if you are
experiencing diarrhea on a drug like
ozempic make sure that you are upping
your water and consider an electrolyte
supplement to prevent dehydration if
you're dehydrated you're gonna feel like
just that I'd check in it's day two
after my second ozempic injection and I
have had two coffees so far because I've
been absent 4 30 I haven't been able to
sleep and it is 11 now 11 A.M and I have
had diarrhea four times already today
um it doesn't feel very good oh God
Ginge I know it is super hard not to
double down on the caffeine when you are
exhausted but definitely not gonna help
the bowels okay it is shot number four
today and that makes it day 22. it's May
30th so here's what I will say about
week three I did not have the same
symptoms as I had week two so week two I
had insane diarrhea last week I was a
bit tired but other than that I didn't
really feel anything physically
um which I think is a good sign but I
was also so I had gallbladder surgery
three weeks before I started a zenbeck
so it was very hard I wasn't allowed to
do physical activity for you know four
weeks I was allowed to gradually resume
at the four week Mark
um so I'm graduate I've gradually
resumed and last week I started you know
going happy I played tennis two or three
times I did Pilates
um so I feel like I'm bouncing back
physically but I have been so hungry so
this is really not curved my appetite at
this dose week three week two I was kind
of afraid to eat almost because I was
having so much diarrhea a case of the
point on the Hunker piece I'm actually
up 0.8 of a pound this week compared to
last week so there's that so here we go
okay so this all makes sense to me uh
0.25 milligrams is still a very low
starter dose so I really wouldn't expect
any dramatic results yet and the 0.8
pounds weight gain could also be totally
normal fluctuations in body weight so
really not a big deal now the increase
in hunger is interesting but it's
probably the body fighting to make up
for the deficit from the week before
because as Ginger said she was kind of
like afraid to eat because of the
diarrhea and she probably dropped a
little bit of water weight as well and I
mean if you've ever been super sick and
like throwing up and having diarrhea and
you haven't felt like eating much for a
few days when you do feel better you are
like ravenous trying to make up for it
so it actually sounds like we're kind of
on the up so far we are a month in at
0.25 milligrams starter dose no weight
loss yet no major impact on appetite
some significant side effects especially
GI side effects but they do seem to be
leveling out at this point though I
would expect that she might have another
rough week or so when she decides to
increase the dose next Ginger will be
doing four weeks at 0.5 milligrams then
four weeks at one milligram and then
she's either gonna stay there or move up
to two milligrams depending on symptoms
outcomes response Etc so there's still a
very long road ahead and anything can
happen here so if you're curious what a
nose Epic Journey looks like from start
to maintenance follow along and we'll
check in with ginger in another month
and on that note if you like this video
please give it the thumbs up subscribe
hit up my bio don't forget to download
my free Hunger crushing combo ebook as
Ginger said it has been revolutionary
for helping her manage her appetite and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye
laughs
[Music]